jo ich melde mich hier von der ibc in
amsterdam das ist die technik messe für
video und fernsehen und um mir ein
bisschen was anzugucken und um das
neueste frage video zu drehen für rolf
eden das ist nämlich einer der
bekanntesten playboy es in deutschland
inzwischen über 80 jahre alt aber immer
eine attraktive frau an seiner seite
warum das so ist das werde ich mit ihm
klären und ich werde auch sprechen über
eure fragen an ihn die wie immer am
besten als video antwort auf dieses
video posten oder in die kommentare
schreiben und den info text lesen und
kreativ sein und dann kann eigentlich
nichts mehr schief gehen
ansonsten bis dahin bleibt dran